nous sommes avec le neveu de sophie
petrona lionel granouillac bonsoir merci
d'être en direct avec nous sur rt france
alors quelles sont les dernières
nouvelles concernant votre tante que
vous pouvez nous partager on sait que
son fils à votre cousin est arrivé à
bamako
écoutez dans la tente toujours de la
confirmation officielle des autorités
françaises mais on sait de par des
recoupements d'informations et non pas
mal de dépêches qui ont dit qu'ils ont
été diffusés assez crédible sur le net
je pense pouvoir dire ce soir qu'elle
est libre qu'elle est en cours
d'acheminement entre gao et et bamako
ce sont les infos les dernières infos
que dont on dispose et donc
effectivement c'est un soulagement pour
elle après presque quatre ans de
captivité
donc j'attends bien sûr le visuel
j'attende je vois que vous diffusé son
portrait avec sébastien mon cousin
j'attends justement cette photo cette
image parce que il s'est battu pendant
quatre ans pour pour la sortir et il
mérite vraiment aujourd'hui 2
le set cette délivrance et j'attends
quand même ce visuel pour être
complètement libérés mais voilà on est
extrêmement confiant la famille et tous
nos proches qui me soutiennent vous nous
le dites ce soir à sophie petrona serait
donc libre après quatre ans de captivité
est ce que vous avez eu des nouvelles
ces derniers jours des autorités du
ministère des affaires étrangères par
exemple est ce que vous étiez en lien
ces derniers temps avec les autorités
pour voir un dossier qui bouge pas du
tout on n'a pas eu de contacts très
récent mise à part pour entre guillemets
une carte d'anniversaire le 7 juillet
pour ses 75 ans ou la cellule de crise à
bien a eu un démocrate bienveillance et
et d'empathie et dont je peux vous dire
que nous sommes en contact évidemment
actuellement que pour l'instant les
autorités françaises ne veulent pas
confirmer tant que je pense ils n'auront
pas eu la certitude qu'elles soient en
sécurité et que le personnel de chez eux
et pu rendre compte
votre combat le combat jo de famille
depuis quatre ans at il enfin porter ses
fruits comment vous vous êtes mobilisés
pendant toutes ces années et tous ces
mois alors c'est difficile de
synthétiser quatre ans de lutte
mais bon on a commencé par créer dès la
revendication de son enlèvement a
commencé par créer un comité de soutien
qui s'appelle libérons tir et sophie
point fr
et ensuite voilà on a pris contact et
surtout sébastien fait de nombreux
voyages sur site
que ce soit au mali au niger plaque
tournante souvent des négociations ou à
nouakchott pour prendre contact pour se
rapprocher au plus près d'elle 2
jusqu'en décembre 2018 à obtenir et bien
d un intermédiaire et un contact fiable
qui aurait pu permettre sa libération un
processus de négociation que l'état
français n'a pas voulu appliquer et donc
la position du président macron était a
toujours été de ne pas vouloir négocier
donc on s'est pas découragée on a avec
mon frère arnaud montclus jean-pierre
aussi on a continué et est soutenu
sébastien aussi dans ses actions
même si ça a été difficile parce que ça
a été beaucoup de sacrifices et je pense
notamment la cousine séverine et à ses
trois enfants qui pendant de longues
semaines à endurer aussi le le spectre
de de ses voyages avec des inquiétudes
de savoir si elle n'y allait revenir
lionel garrigues ac malheureusement le
temps qui nous est imparti va bientôt se
terminer voilà en tout cas ce soir vous
nous le dit sophie petrona est en route
apparemment à vers la liberté on attend
bien entendu la confirmation des
autorités en tout cas un grand merci
pour votre témoignage lionel
grenouillage rappelle que vous êtes le
neveu de sophie petrona